now tell me if this
[Applause]
[Music]
look around you
versus gone home we're still standing
Russian Reds drunken Ted forgive me for
being slightly biased this time but come
on you Reds
[Music]
greetings and salutations all you raw
takers now today we are in a sunny and
sizzling hot Spanish capital of Madrid
obviously the host city of the 2019
Champions League final but I will bring
your raw live uncut emotions from the
streets of Madrid come on
[Music]
[Applause]
just the night before the final and
Madrid is basically red
got ahem fans of somewhere to be seen
look at that
don't look at that listen to that
[Applause]
[Music]
we've heard that song before many times
[Applause]
kind of power
I imagine walking the streets of Madrid
the night before the Champions League
final
you're just roaming around people in red
people in white and then you come across
something like this no no I mean like
listen wait wait wait sorry just look
russian Reds drunken Ted's and why the
[ __ ] do you support Liverpool
listen let them sit let's let's let's
leave that subject no tell me something
tell me something I may get me on come
on you execute execute I do not exist no
right just tell me what are you thoughts
ahead of the game I mean like let's just
be let's be normal people all right it
will fans right we know we're gonna win
oh that's a good statement though okay
live we think we're gonna win we hope we
can influence their [ __ ] 22 players
on the pitch toilet you know it I wish
no fan this is anything an influence
tell me something which actually boggles
my mind have you guys got a ticket for
the game you have because I'm a Russian
star great so so basically what I'm
seeing here most of the time is people
complaining about you a for handling all
this but you need to turn the camera
even though this is not my team all of
these people have not got tickets
that's my point that's why I asked you
because I was interested to hear from
the Spurs reporters none uneasy good
singers
I mean the Reds although the whites rich
boy
you haven't got a ticket
oh yeah good TV smiles but you but you
hope you get one right the final one I
so wait where you going to watch it if
you don't have a ticket
well we'll see they have a screen there
but they're not guaranteeing that they
will show it that is the problem I mean
guys for you it must be must be like
harder because it's your first European
final the major one right kids it's just
crazy to me I wasn't Kiev last year
obviously that Kiev was organized
somewhat better than Madrid and absolute
vitrines well-organized it's absolutely
fantastic
I'm tickets I'm talking about the
screening nose raises but that is the
room isn't it is he bear that would be
the right thing to know look you get
everyone in one place
a hundred thousand
[Applause]
so I just spoke to a bunch of sports
fans yeah they told me an interesting
thing would I get you on the show ok I
got it no no they say that Liverpool
fans think they will win it
we Spurs fans hope we'll always do you
think it's the real case ok
it's one of game
[Music]
we plant dust here together
again
[Music]
we're gonna believe happy that sounds so
poetic I have to tell you that no
excuses right means last year that there
could be some excuse like okay we're
playing against reality
anyway he worked to be there this year
he worked is over
so I don't think they even if referee's
decision we worked we went install
gainst us
injuries happen the team is mature that
they can get movin up the dog sit there
talking about it their work and get over
it
let's see you know I was in Liverpool
three weeks ago for the last game and
the most surprising thing to me was that
I was going around asking people we
probably gonna lose the league today I
mean there's a very slim chance of us
winning it but do you feel sad or
downbeat about it and everyone's like
after for Neil against Barcelona [ __ ] no
our journey always asking other people
don't stand that's not mother
we're tired of explaining it yoku is not
just come now go away and maybe maybe
not bear with it and we'll keep on going
because that's what we do
you know things are down no problems we
know we can come back up we have that
belief we have that installed in us over
the years
emulation Corp in English the main stand
any road king Kenny's you name it all
for periods of believe in the same thing
then we travel out here in our thousands
and multiple ten thousands people not
we'll take over the city it was yeah
look around you expose is going home
we're still standing so good
[Music]
[Applause]
it's something weird in your
neighborhood who you gonna call and it
don't look good who you go
[Applause]
nope
[Music]
[Applause]
she shot great yes we couldn't wait for
tomorrow
likewise
[Applause]
hi this is my main hobby fun yes I guess
okay come on come on come on like a
glove
grappa you know you know what I got oh
it's actually pink
I think it's actually pink because we
never give up right now you look proper
Habibi
and so I want it that's what I wanted
genuine genuine stuff look look the
girls like I get it giving your
attention already great great oh man
thank you he sold me medium medium
medium medium medium yeah see
[Applause]
I know it's a night before the final but
this final is all about one thing
essentially
[Music]
what
come from oh yeah
I don't just like I would go there
together but because how many were like
the chickens
yeah
if I don't have a ticket how is so happy
you know like to share experiences
and just myself you know question the
way you traveled all the way from Brazil
being a spur support Duchy I don't have
it
30 hours and you don't care
enjoy myself this all happen here for
you also have a beautiful mustache
[Music]
it's actually really incredible and
eclectic so on the day of the big
Champions League final in Madrid when
horses roaming the streets of the
Spanish capital there is a beautiful
vigil right by the palace life goes on
even when football is in town
[Music]
have to say though it's not a struggle
really but it's not that easy to find
Spurs fans in Madrid I would say the
city is predominantly red Liverpool
jerseys are literally like every way if
I just turn around see there's like red
everywhere girls and boys from all over
the world but I still managed to catch
up with a bunch of Smurfs fans actually
I see one now let's go try to talk I
mean it's interesting because you're
sitting in a group having some reason
beers and there's a first guy with a
wine no by no means I'm trying to say is
it's interesting the you know the number
of Liverpool fans a number of Spurs fans
what's what's the right place most of
them arrived today this morning right
yeah I run this morning we have run in
the parks muscle suit half a dozen
agencies since Tuesday and it's been
pretty much livable yeah the theory is
that the Spurs fans have to go to work
it's good the two English teams are
playing it's actually a certificate of
respect
to England and it's good to see everyone
I'm genuinely genuinely very good man I
wish them the best but we gotta win this
the confidence is low people good
feeling about it just being here already
have you guys got tickets yeah yeah
Lucky's first fans got tickets yeah I'm
going to the game as well but I I mean
I've seen that's the biggest problem
around people are searching for tickets
every Finals like that but this time is
something I think there's more fear
believable it's easier for spurs fallacy
interest expense per school first spend
you will see tell me are you how you got
a ticket
are you the luck you want to get a
ticket because I know it's one of the
biggest problems in Madrid so far like
lots of ridiculous fans anyway for
screwing people over are you guys lucky
in the lucky lot yeah I mean I'm going
to the stick as well I'm yeah it's not
that I'm like fishing for tickets but
already we do you think do you think
it's it's fair for fans I mean I know
that Spurs fans got more tickets in a
way than Liverpool fans because the
fight for tickets was a little less
intense among the Spurs fans because a
little crazy
well become we've got more CNC router
names we were bigger club the names
how's that so so well I'm Dena we're
bigger okay so we're we had this first
fans I mean earth I mean there are a lot
but Liverpool got support outside of
equipment yeah baby look at us in sunny
- there's only be wearing a special
these guys - no there's well suppose
fancier you don't see yeah yeah so
they're just not making ourselves loud
yet right there's a lot of little faith
I mean every bit because they've been a
big club from the wall every night right
if Spurs win tonight do you think the
fan base will expand dramatically after
that win as it often happens with teams
well I'm doing it home I mean I think
yeah and liver for was probably one
might any difference will it because
they advise is really big anyway what
would you welcome this expansion of yes
because we'll money and we get better
flyer and maybe you'll start buying
players a transfer
[Applause]
defecting you're not bother that you
don't have it
not really I'm not gonna risk trying to
find it odd favor
so you just here for the party of course
yeah Sammy's kid there for the party we
had a party
we got beat what we had a party
[Applause]
now Madrid has installed several
so-called fan zones like you've got a
stage right here the concert and all
that stuff a lot of people obviously but
there's been many concerns about the
screening of the file because there are
tens of thousands of ticketless fans and
it's still unclear whether there will be
any public screening of the game there
are rumors that it will be but those are
just rumors the question is whether all
the pubs in the city will be able to
accommodate thank you so much we'll be
able to accommodate all the ticketless
fans and those are huge numbers
believers
[Applause]
[Music]
if you had any questions about what
color Madrid is today
it's obviously red has Madrid ever been
this red sound is apart
I could see laughs but there's nothing
down the rest of the laps ain't got it's
us we'll have to live in America well
imma let me know I'm laughing for fun
I'm the goalie the number one you can
[Applause]
know as I've done in previous editions
of my blog but ticking off from
Liverpool boss night which is the
biggest concert for Liverpool fans
around so this guy right here right here
right here this guy Jamie Webster he's
gonna light up the atmosphere so fans
will be highly energized before they
take to the stadium but just to give you
an idea what's going on in the city of
Madrid they say you know Spain is red I
would say Madrid is drop a red right now
you just got to check this out this is
game
[Music]
let's [ __ ] do this
hey Doc
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm moving you're a bagel
[Applause]
yes here's the man he's gonna light this
place on fire
[Music]
[Applause]
who's ready to pounce
lemme see
we have read about
Oh
[Music]
tell me
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] law
o kzr the chamois the fields about feel
you
[Music]
[Applause]
how we
[Music]
[Applause]
I have to say I've had numerous
journalistic challenges of my days
covering warfare chief noble in all
those things but this is one of the
hardest ones trying to be objective
being a hardcore Liverpool fan so
everyone watching or take forgive me for
being slightly biased this time but come
on you Reds
[Applause]
six times six times
[Music]
[Applause]